antoine bonjour alors d'après berlin
alexeï navalni a été empoisonnée et pas
par n'importe quel agent neurotoxiques
puisqu'on parle de nos vies de choc
oui nos vies de choc le mot a été lâché
il s'agit de cette substance
rappelez vous cette substance
neurotoxique qui aurait été la cause de
l'empoisonnement d'après les autorités
britanniques de cet ex officier des
renseignements russes ainsi que de sa
fille sergueï skripal et yulia skripal à
salisbury en mars 2018 en croire le
porte-parole du gouvernement du
gouvernement allemand c'est bien une
substance de la même famille que ce
novice choc qui aurait été découverte
dans l'organisme de l'opposant russe
actuellement hospitalisé dans un hôpital
de berlin je vous propose de regarder un
extrait de ce communiqué du gouvernement
allemand à la demande de l'hôpital
universitaire de la charité
le laboratoire spéciale des forces
armées d'allemagne a effectué une étude
toxicologique des échantillons de
matières biologiques d'alexei navalni
les résultats de l'étude confirment sans
équivoque la présence d'un agent
chimique neurotoxiques du groupe novice
choc le parlement allemand qui on vient
d'apprendre se réserve le droit
d'introduire de nouvelles sanctions
contre moscou l'ambassadeur de russie en
allemagne a d'ailleurs été convoqué en
urgence au ministère allemand des
affaires étrangères du côté de la russie
cette nouvelle a été accueillie avec
circonscrite circonspection et on a
demandé
du côté de la russie on a demandé à
avoir accès aux données qui permettent
de tirer de telles conclusions tout cas
lui ministère russe des affaires
étrangères n'a pas été informée sur la
question et l'a appris de la même façon
que tout le monde via la presse antoine
claireaux en direct de moscou
merci pour ces précisions